wir hatten die letzten sitzung was zu
gluten gesagt wir hatten auch viel
gesagt zu platon dann mache ich dann
oben rechts wieder ein link rhein zu
dieser sitzung der idee des guten die
idee des guten hatten sie gesehen die
ist irgendwie über allem sein denn
stehend und platon spricht selbst gar
nicht direkt von der idee des bösen die
gibt es bei platz und gar nicht
vielleicht wird er sogar ein widerspruch
ist ja auch eine spannende frage für
eine seminar leistung was platin über
das böse zu sagen hat angesichts seiner
idee des guten wir hatten also gesehen
platon fast das gute als idee als
erkenntnis grunddesign also wir können
durch die idee des guten erkennen was
ist und wir können eben auch durch die
idee des guten erklären warum etwas ist
als es der erkenntnis grund und der
science grund und wir hatten dann
verschiedene gleichnisse kurz gelesen
bei platin als es gibt mit platten des
sonnen gleichnis platten vergleicht das
gute oder die idee des guten mit der
sonne da gibt es das linien gleichnis
oder gibts das höhlengleichnis da habe
ich eine grafik aus diesem dtv atlas
philosophie eingeblendet die ich
ziemlich hilfreich finden weil da werden
die ganzen drei gleichnisse aufeinander
projiziert das sieht man diesen ganzen
zusammenhang sehr gut und jetzt haben
wir uns gefragt wo steht denn dann
bitteschön das böse in diesen ganzen
gleichnissen wo kann man es verordnen
wir hatten dann gesagt also vielleicht
ganz unten in dieser hierarchie de sein
denn also bei den schatten bildern bei
dem was sich auch uns entzieht was uns
täuscht da oder vielleicht sogar noch
weiter unten das eine ganz spannende
fragen und platin ist jetzt ein neuer
platonischer
der
platons gedanken weiter entwickelt hat
aber ziemlich eigenständig sie sehen
auch der ist also circa 400 jahre jünger
als platin platten oder sogar noch mehr
als 600 jahre fast
dann war ja so im vierten jahrhundert
vor christus und das ist jetzt das
dritte jahrhundert nach da sind einige
jahre vergangen platin ist auf jeden
fall für die ganze antike spätantike
auch für augustinus aber da natürlich
auch für das mittelalter sehr zentral
und jetzt möchte ich hier erstmals in
die leitfragen darstellen also wie
bestimmt kloten das verhältnis von gut
und böse liefern ist das böse eine
beraubung des guten das hatten wir in
der letzten sitzung schon angedeutet und
jetzt möchte ich aber zu beginn erst mal
was über das gute bei blue jeans sagen
das ist ein zitat das hatten sie nicht
von mir bekommen das ist findet sich
auch in diesen jahren und das möchte ich
mal vorlesen weil er das gute ganz auf
eine ganz interessante weise mit dem
einen in eine verbindung also dass
hennen griechische händen man spricht
auch von einer technologie eine lehre
des einen für kloten ist das eine und
das gute so eng miteinander verwoben
also das eine ist kann man sich so ein
bisschen vorstellen wie die idee des
guten bei platon das steht ja immer so
ein bisschen hintergrund und ich möchte
es jetzt einfach mal vorlesen alles
andere ist durch das eine einiges groß
geschrieben seien sowohl das was
ursprünglich seien ist als auch das west
irgendwie zudem sein denn gezählt wird
denn was sollte es auch sein wenn es
nicht 1 mehrere der jenes das einem raub
nicht ist was es genannt wird und es
gibt weder ein her wenn es keine einheit
geben soll noch einen chor noch eine
herde ohne einheit aber auch ein haus
oder ein schiff gibt es nicht ohne dass
sie das eine haben wenn anders das haus
das schiff eine einheit bilden wenn sie
diese verloren haben so dass das haus
nicht ein haus und das schiff nicht mehr
schiff
kontinuierlichen größen hören demnach
auf die sein wenn in ihnen das eine
nicht vorhanden ist er teilt wenigstens
alt er ihren zieht das seien insofern
als sie das eine zerstören ebenso auch
die körper der pflanzen und tiere
während jeder eine einheit bildet wenn
sie in eine vielheit serien dass eine
verlassen so vernichtend ihr eigenes
wesen und sind nicht mehr was sie waren
so sind andere geworden und zwar jene
die vermöge einer einheit existieren
also die einheit ist das eine ist das
was das ding zum ding macht was dieses
ding diesen gegenstand die einheit gibt
und wir werden jetzt gleich sehen das
protein diese einheit mit dem begriff
des guten in eine ganz interessante
verbindung bringt
er sagte mich da es also eins ist was
wir suchen und da wir das prinzip aller
dinge betrachten das gute und das erste
so muss wir das prinzip und eine schauen
will einerseits sich nicht entfernen von
der umgebung des ersten und nicht in das
allerletzte herabsinken sondern er muss
streben sich selbst in das erste
zurückzuführen von den äußersten
sinnliche den und von aller
schlechtigkeit frei sein da er ja zum
guten strebten andererseits muss er
aufgestiegen sein zu dem prinzip in sich
und eins aus vielen geworden sein er
muss als intellekt werden und seine
eigene seele dem intellekt anvertrauen
und festnehmen gründen damit sie was
jeder schaut wachen aufnehmen und
hiermit wusste dass eine schauen ohne
irgendeine sinnliche wahrnehmung oder
etwas von ihr her in jenen aufzunehmen
sondern mit dem reinen intellekt muss er
das reinste schauen und mit der ersten
kraft des intellekts als wir sehen hier
das clowns idee des guten hier pate
gestanden hat
wir sehen dass er sich von den
sinnlichen dingen
abgrenzt das mag ich mal kurz ein
bisschen alle die sinnliche dinge hier
von den sinnlichen dingen müssen wir uns
sozusagen abwenden wir müssen aufsteigen
von der schlechtigkeit frei ist sein das
heißt hier könnte man schon so ein
bisschen das böse erkennen
und aufsteigen also das ist wieder so
ein bisschen dieses höhlengleichnis bei
planern wir sind erst in der
schattenwelt ganz unten in der höhle und
müssen dann aufsteigend zu dem prinzip
das ist bei platon die idee des guten
und hier bei platin ist sie ist es das
prinzip um das 1 davon spricht platt und
nicht so sehr von dem 1 aber er würde es
sicherlich auch ähnlich sagen kloten ist
hier noch ein bisschen differenzierter
in der interpretation dieses
höhlengleichnis der idee des guten also
ganz ähnlich wie bei platon rekrutin das
schlechte ist irgendwie unten so seien
in der höhle im schattenreich und wir
müssen aufsteigen zum einen mit hilfe
unseres intellekt und dieses eine ist
auch das gute
und jetzt wollen wir noch ein bisschen
näher über das böse putin was ließen ich
hatte es schon in der letzten sitzung
ein bisschen angedeutet als ich sagt die
untersuchung woher das böse dakar-sieg
akon ist das böse oder schlechte sieht
man die frage immer das übersetzt ich
hatte ja gesagt in der antike oder auch
im lateinischen heißt das schlechte oder
das böse mal um also das ist das wort
dasselbe wort mal um kann sowohl für das
schlechte wie auch für das böse
gebraucht werden wir sagen heutzutage
schlecht und böse wie unterscheiden da
zwischendurch zwei wörter im
lateinischen im griechischen bedeutet
ein wort malen oder griechisch kaka zwei
verschiedene dinge nämlich schlecht und
böse unterscheiden gar nicht dass hier
das was schlecht ist ist das böse und
das was das böse ist das schlecht wir
hingegen würden sagen ja das war jetzt
eine schlechte leistung das war schlecht
aber das ist nicht böse wir haben da
noch mehr differenzen weil das böse für
uns immer eine moralische bedeutung hat
das schlechte ich nicht unbedingt werden
das ist ein schlechter apfel könnten wir
sagen oder ein fauler apfel
die griechen und die lateiner hätten
eben gesagt mal um oder kakos wir hatten
es gesehen an dem messer es gibt ein
schlechtes messer das er war sozusagen
die funktion nicht erfüllt aber das ist
noch nichts moralischen also hier ist
diese moralische bedeutung immer drin
ist schon in dem begriff deswegen hätte
ganz generell von einem schlechten oder
bösen gesprochen einfach im gegensatz
zum guten zu dieser idee des guten also
die untersuchung oder das böse in das
seiende das ist dass bonn oder darunter
die seine dinge überhaupt in eine
bestimmte art design gekommen ist dürfte
tastend mit der frage beginn was
eigentlich das böse und die natur des
büßt sei denn so ließe sich erkennen
woher es gekommen wo es seinen sitz hat
und wem es zustößt überhaupt entscheiden
ob es zur klasse die seinem gehöre durch
welche vermögen uns jedoch die natur des
bösen erkennen sollen da die erkenntnis
jedes dinges aufgrund einer ähnlichkeit
mit demselben vor sich geht dürfte eine
schwierige frage sein den geist und
seele können uns als sie den auch nur
die erkenntnis von ideen zu wege bringen
und auf sie ihr streben richten die will
aber jemand das böse als idee vorstellen
dass gerade in der abwesenheit der as is
alles guten des agathon zu erscheinen
kommt das ist genau das problem was wir
bei platon sehen wie können wir denn die
idee des bösen
erkennen wenn doch das böse oder
schlechte immer in einem mangel besteht
also wenn es eigentlich ihr das nichts
ist ich kann doch nicht nichts erkennen
nichts lässt sich gar nicht erkennen
also wirklich das problem welchen unter
logischen status das böse hat
und hier ist jetzt die ganz berühmte
oder auch sehr prägende
bestimmung des bösen für eine ganze
tradition
das böse als abwesenheit oder vielleicht
sogar auch beraubung der ist kann auch
heißen beratung die beraubung des guten
das ist also die auffassung dass böse
oder schlechter ist nur ein mangel am
guten
es gibt ja ein bisschen eine
problematische situation weil sicherlich
und das schlechte ein apfel der blick
ist oder ein messer was nicht schneidet
nicht gut schneidet könnte man
sicherlich sagen das ist einfach ein
mangel an guten es ist ein mangel an
schärfe zum beispiel stumpf sein ein
stumpfes messer das müsste mal wieder
geschliffen werden das ist einfach ein
mangel der schärfe beim schlechten
trifft es sicherlich zu aber beim bösen
beim moralisch bösen kann man sich jetzt
wirklich fragen ist das moralisch böse
nur einen mangel an guten ist es ein
defizitärer zustand sicherlich ist es
nicht gut aber ist es vielleicht noch
ein bisschen mehr als nur ein mangel ist
da mehr drin geschieht ja nicht mehr
auch mit bezug auf das gute im bösen das
gibt also verschiedene auffassungen das
ist die präventions- theorie die hier
formuliert ist er ist es die abwesenheit
oder der mangel des guten im bösen oder
schlecht ganz prominenten wenn aber weil
es für die gegensätze ein gesetz
erkenntnis gibt und dem guten das böse
entgegengesetzt ist die kenntnis des
guten auch die des bösen sein wird so
müssen diejenigen welche dass das
erkennen wollen genau das gute kennen
wir ja das bessere zum schlechteren
vorangeht und form ist dies aber nicht
sein vielmehr beraubung derselben
gleichwohl ist es noch die frage wie
denn das gute den bösen entgegengesetzt
ist ob das eine die erste das andere die
letzte stelle einnimmt oder das eine als
form das andere als berauschend
betrachtet wird hier ist wieder die
frage nach diesem ganz schwierigen
verhältnis von gut und böse wir hatten
das auch in der erster letzten sitzung
besprochen
wie wie kann man sich denn das
verhältnis von gut und böse jetzt
überhaupt vorstellen gibt es ganz viele
möglichkeiten man kann sich das
vorstellen und polaris modell wie so ein
magnet wo irgendwie oben nordpol ist es
gute und unten im südpol ist das böse
und alles was man in den zwischen
feldern
verortet wie zb eisenspäne sie kennt es
bestimmt aus dem physikunterricht das
ordnet sich irgendwie diesen feldlinien
also alles zeigt auf das richtet sich
auf das gute hin und dementsprechend
eben auch vom verbessere der schlechten
weg so könnte man das einerseits
beschreiben dann hätte man auch
irgendwie das gute und das böse nur als
gegenseitige negationen gefasst alle das
gute ist das nicht böse und das böse ist
das nicht gut das wäre auch dieses konto
aktionsmodell und das scheint irgendwie
diesem verhältnis nicht ganz gerecht
dann hatten wir noch andere modelle eben
das präventionsmodell und dann was ich
noch angeführt hatte dieses modell das
man das gute das böse nicht als
irgendwelche prinzipien in der welt an
setzt sondern als formen unsere
handlungen unserer freiheit und dann
sind sich gut und böse nicht mehr
kontradiktorischen entgegengestellt sind
dann tun wir immer auch was mit dem
guten wenn wir böse handeln weil wie es
zum beispiel mißbrauchen wir geben vor
dass das was wir tun eigentlich gut ist
das heißt wir brauchen das gute dazu
aber
pervertieren gewissermaßen das gute vom
bösen also gut und böse sind viel
intimer miteinander verwoben werden wir
sie auf unsere freie handlung beziehen
als hier sind wenn wir sie als
prinzipien und so weiter fassen das
verhältnis von gut und böse
verkompliziert sich noch entschieden
wenn wir das gut und böse nicht nur als
dinge oder prinzipien fassen oder als
ideen fassen sind als etwas was wir
selbst wir wirken und das betrifft
generell die antike bei platin und bei
platon dass sie nicht so sehr fragen
nach unserem verhältnis zum gut und böse
sind nach der frage wie wir das gute
böse erkennen können aber nicht die
frage wie wir selbst die ursache des
guten und bösen sind diese frage stellen
sich diese denker noch nicht existiert
einfach das böse oder gute in der welt
und wir müssen uns fragen wie wir es
erkennen können
ja das ist also zumindest schon
angeklungen weiter sagte putin jetzt
soll gesagt werden wie ich es die natur
des guten ist soweit es die gegenwärtige
untersuchung erfordert es ist aber das
wenige an dem alles hängt nach dem alles
sein dass strebt da ist derselbe zu
seinem prinzip hat und seiner bedarf es
selbst ist mangel los also gegen die
privaten story auch sich selber genug
nichts bedürfen aller maß dinge maß und
grenze aus sich selbst geist mit
wesenheit und sälen und leben und
geistige tätigkeit spenden und bis zu
ihm hin ist alles schön denn er selbst
der geist ist der herr über das schöne
und jenseits des besten an könig im
reich des geistes dabei ist der geist
nicht in der art wie man etwa nach dem
schließen könnte was uns geist genannt
wird geiste die aus logischen prämissen
ihren inhalt gewinnen wenn sie ihr
verständnis erlangen durch logische
operationen und reflexion über grund und
folge die nach dem sattel des
zureichenden grundes dass seine schauen
als welche vorher nicht hatten sondern
vor ihm lernen obwohl geister doch leer
waren also ein ziemlich komplizierter
satz hier ist jetzt erst mal
entscheidend wie gut ihm das gute
bestimmt als mangel los also gerade die
entgegengesetzt zu lösen was sie ein
mangel ist das maß aller dinge als
irgendwie auch normativ also wenn wir
etwas an etwas bewerten dann ist das
auch das maß der maßstab hier stecken
normativität drin
und auch seele und leben und auch noch
interessant hier schön
das gute ist nach blut ihn auch noch das
schöne also man könnte sagen dass eine
das wahre die norm die normativität das
schöne da gibt es ganz verschiedene
beschreiben des guten und vor diesem
hintergrund muss man jetzt eben sich
auch überlegen wie das böse zu verstehen
ist hier hat er noch eine bemerkung über
den geist der news das ist das vermögen
mit dem wir eben die idee des guten auch
nach platon erkennen und hier grenzte
sich jetzt eben von einer auffassung von
rationalität ab die im sinne von
logischen schlussfolgerung funktioniert
also
logisch operation reflexion über grund
und folge das ist eine form der
erkenntnis die nach blut ihn nicht zum
guten führt das ist das was platon die
diana nennen das ist das logische
schließen die diana unterscheidet platon
vom uci diana ist nach partnern für
mathematische gegenstände da die auch
ideen darstellen also mathematische
gegenstände wie dreiecke die zahlen sind
auch ideen aber wenn sie sich noch mal
genau dieses linien gleichen das
anschauen dann sind dies ideen der
mathematik nicht das höchste sein dass
das höchstes sein ist eben die idee des
guten und die idee des guten kann
deswegen nicht mit diesen menschlichen
vermögen erkannt werden mit dem wir
mathematische gegenstand erkennt das ist
nämlich ein schlussfolgern des denkens
ein denken über verschiedene schritte
hinweg prämissen konfusionen dass das
detektiv bedenken oder das diskursive
denken das wenige was platten und dann
auch protein als vermögen mit der idee
des guten in verbindung bringen ist
nicht das diskursive denken dass
verschiedene schritte kennen sind das
intuitive dem das unmittelbare erfassen
sowie wir zum beispiel auch etwas sehen
und unmittelbar wahrnehmen so muss man
sich nach platten und lud ihn die
wahrnehmung des guten und des 1
vorstellen also wirklich eine schau eine
unmittelbare wesen so kann man es auch
nennen des guten und nichts was
irgendwie vermittelt ist über
verschiedene reduktion warum kann man
sich auch fragen warum muss es eine
wesen chance sein warum muss es sein und
ganz einfach weil wenn es wirklich das
eine ist das prinzip und das gute dann
muss es eben unmittelbar sein kann es
nicht wie mathematische gegenstände in
relation zu anderen stehen im kognitiven
sinne erst erschlossen werden aus etwas
das würde nach beratungen pro team der
idee des absoluten das wieder so ein
begriff den beiden jetzt nicht direkt
verwenden der da war auch mit zusammen
des absoluten widersprechen wenn etwas
wirklich absolut gut ist dann muss es so
die auffassung von platin und lud ihn
unmittelbar geschaut werden und nicht
der dutti verschlossen werden über
verschiedene schritte das ist so dieser
gedanke nach dem
diesen denken also jedes gute und böse
fallen das gute hat er mir spezifisch
apps theologische auszeichnung dass wir
das eine wie zum beispiel zahlen nur
vermittelt mittelbar erkennen über
schlüssel das gute und das schöne und
das waren die norm unmittelbar news wenn
du diese art der seite über das
seien dennoch erhaben ist so kann das
böse nicht in dem sein dennoch im
jenseits des seinen sich befinden denn
dieses beides ist gut also jenseits des
sein das war die idee des guten bei
platons erinnern sich noch da sagt er
die idee des guten muss jenseits nach
dass seitens sein weil die idee des
guten das seien überhaupt erst möglich
macht das war diese transzendenz des
guten nach platon und es kann aber auch
nicht sein denn sein weil das sei eben
immer anteil hat an der idee des guten
und sich die idee des guten verdankt als
das böse kann nicht sein denn noch
jenseits zu sein als sein anwalt das ist
gut es bleibt also übrig dass wenn
überhaupt
es in dem nicht sein ist gleichsam wie
eine gewisse form des nicht sein denn an
etwas mit nicht sein den vermischten
oder irgendwie mit dem nicht sein dass
in gemeinschafts stehenden das nicht
sein ist aber keineswegs das unbedingt
nicht sein deshalb nur etwas anderes als
der seine auch nicht so nicht sein wie
bewegung und ruhe am sein denn und jetzt
kommt die bestimmung soll wie ein bild
des sein denn oder noch viel mehr nicht
sein
dies ist aber die ganze sinnen fällige
welt also die welt der sinne die
erscheinung und attraktionen am sinnen
fälligen oder noch etwas hinter diesen
oder wie ein akzidenz für dasselbe oder
prinzip desselben oder etwas was bei
gleicher beschaffenheit dasselbe
vollzählig macht und so könnte man sich
denn etwa eine vorstellung von ihm
machen nach der es
maßlosigkeit sei gegenüber den maßen
unbegrenztes gegenüber der grenze
umgestaltetes gegenüber den gestalteten
stets bedürftiges gegenüber dem
selbstgenügsam stets unbestimmt nirgends
feststehen einleitend und gesättigt und
so weiter und so fort also hier sieht
man es ist ziemlich dem guten
entgegengesetzt weil das gute ja gerade
das maß war und die grenze war ja also
hier ist ganz entscheidend das böse ist
jetzt nicht das reine nicht sein de sind
das kurz vor dem nicht sein deshalb das
wenige was das sein irgendwie stört und
das muss ja irgendwie sein um das seine
zerstören muss ja das böse irgendwie
eine gewisse präsenz haben aber es ist
eben eine präsenz der unordnung oder man
könnte auch sagen eine un-präsenz ein
unding könnte man auch sagen da gibt es
ja diesen begriff ist und als
irgendetwas was das gute das eine das
maß das schöne stört aber könnte zum
beispiel sagen es ist auch das hässliche
das hässliche wäre auch eine
phänomenologische form eine
manifestation des bösen zumindest nach
platin also hat einen sehr reichhaltigen
sehr offenen sehr anschaulichen begriff
des bösen wie auch des guten
ja bei welcher daseinsform ist das nun
aber vorhanden ohne von ihr verschiedene
sein sollen als sie selbst denn wenn das
böse einem anderen als eigenschaft
zukommt so muss es zuvor selbst etwas an
und für sich sein wenn es auch keine
bestimmte wesenheit ist also es ist
keine bestimmte wesenheit aber es muss
doch irgendwie sein oder zumindest an
etwas anderen zahlen also es ist
vielleicht nicht eigenständig
unabhängig von anderen aber es ist
zumindest an anderen dran denn wie es
ein an sich gutes ein anderes als
eigenschaft gibt es da gibt es auch ein
an sich böses und ein böses dass die
sinngemäß ich an einem anderen als
eigenschaft findet
was gibt es nun für eine maßlosigkeit
also die maßlosen aber wie es ein maß
gibt außerhalb des gemessenen zu auch
eine maßlosigkeit außerdem maßlosen denn
wenn sie in einem anderen ist so ist
entweder im maßlosen aber selbst maßlos
bedarf es der maßlosigkeit nicht oder im
gemessenen aber das gemessene kann als
solches unmöglich maßlosigkeit haben
folglich muss es ein an sich unbegrenzt
ebenso ein ansicht gestalt loses geben
und was sonst noch die natur des
maßlosen
charakterisiert und wenn etwas nach ihm
so beschaffen ist so hat es dies
entweder durchmischung oder es ist so
durch das hin blicken auf jenes oder es
bringt etwas derartiges hervor also das
den gestalten und formen und maßen und
grenzen zu grunde liegende und mit
fremden schmuck geschmückte nicht gutes
an sich haben etwas das ein schattenbild
es sein denn aber dass des bösen
wesenheit ist das ist also ganz
interessant hier sagt er jetzt dass das
böse sich mit fremden schmuck schmückt
und das finde ich schon ziemlich modern
wenn sie auch mal hier denken an böse
taten böse handlungen tatsächlich könnte
man sagen wer sich mit fremden federn
schmückt der tod zumindest etwas
unmoralisches nicht erzeugt scheint er
führt einen in die irre also hier finde
ich jetzt schon wirklich sehr
bezeichnetes charakteristikum des bösen
was ich auch beziehen lässt auf unsere
handlungen und nicht nur auf das was in
der wetten abhängig von uns existiert
und jetzt komplett ihn auf die körper zu
sprechen die natur der körper also
soweit sie an der materie teil hat ist
böse es würden wir heutzutage überhaupt
nicht sagen
also
körper die materiell sind inwiefern sind
die denn böse
ja selbst inwiefern 7 die den schlecht
warum soll etwas was an der materie teil
hat schlecht sein wir kommen gleich
drauf wenn die aufzeichnung ist denn sie
haben eine nicht wahrhafte form sind des
lebens beraubt sie vernichten sich
gegenseitig durch die von ihnen
ausgehende ungeordnete bewegung sie
hemmen die seelen ihrer eigentümlichen
tätigkeit als ewige schließend fließen
sie fliehen sie die wesenheit die seele
aber ist nicht an sich böse auch nicht
jede böse aber welches ist die böse
seele diejenige sagt platin welche sich
einen menschen dienstbar gemacht hat den
von natur die schlechtigkeit der seele
angeboren ist nehmt die unvernünftige
form der seele das böse aufnimmt nämlich
maßlosigkeit übermaß mangel aus denen
auch zügellosigkeit und feigheit und die
sonstige schlechtigkeit der serie stammt
unfreiwillige leidenschaften welche
falsche meinung veranlassen dass für
schlecht und gut zu halten wofür sie
flieht und wonach sich strebt also hier
sehen wir jetzt plötzlich ein bezug auf
die natur der körper auf das materielle
das kann man natürlich wieder von platon
her verstehen denken sind auch man
dieses liegen gleichnis zurück die
ontologie was ist ganz unten und was es
ganz oben in der rai der existenz ganz
oben ist dass herr abstrakte das ideelle
die idee des guten ganz unten sind die
schattenbilder aber auch eben auch die
gegenstimme die gegenstände die
physischen körperlichen dinge kommen
gleich nach den schatten bildern dann
kommen die ideen und dann die
mathematischen gegenstände und dann
kommen kommt ganz oben die idee des
guten und hier würde ich jetzt mal die
auszeichnung beenden damit wir dann in
die diskussion über gehen können